madame marois lot de venir nous
rejoindre à ce que dans comment ça va
cartonner ses locaux mais ses
déclarations j'ai pas nous faire un peu
fallait pas certes il ne fallait pas si
sa chanson préférée est la norme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans famille sans faute en battant
puisque ont tué dans la nuit un peu
palpitante
prix
[Musique]
cette année
à l'aller s'était piqué gros
[Musique]
allez
les
ils ont fait de la délation et fait
désormais payer pour leur participation
dans l'émission doré peas the voice
marois nous marque le rythme ça en fait
avec ça dit vas-y tu as détesté
pas envie de faire sourire ces symboles
sont pas non je suis patient
[Rires]
donner
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
c
je t'embrasse
merci merci des désastres
j 10 m plus de 10 millions de stream
pour ceux qui d'un carton et et toi ma
chérie bien sûr c'est pour toi si une
gueule d'or plus de deux mois c'est
encore une question pour marwa moi c'est
quand la dernière fois qu un coup de
coeur pour un mec là et jamais
réellement eu le coup de coeur pour un
bourrin mais qu à la vincent pons et
comme gérant mieux non l'émission n'est
pas terminée en france que j'ai encore
le temps de voir et ton style au total
neuf soirées qui paraissait le son si la
table
on attend ils sont cinquante ans
et
ce soir ou jamais petit maurice tout
nascar